if you look at it the energy industry is
what powers everything else
transportation healthcare medicine
education and over the last hundred 20
years since the Industrial Revolution
the average human beings lifespan has
increased 20% because of the abundance
and reliability of fossil fuels is the
main source of energy that we have my
name is Deacon sloths and I'm the CEO
and co-founder of tackiest I'm 25 years
old
tackiest helps oil companies extract
value out of their data so they have
lots of different types of data
production data subsurface logs and
seismic information and many of the
world's largest oil companies have
invested tens of billions of dollars in
gathering new sources of data but
they're still looking for the answer to
the questions how do I turn that data
into business value how do I increase my
profit margin cut my costs increase my
production tackiest is the answer to
that and as a consequence a lot of the
operators have been working with an
increase their production significantly
on average about 20 percent actually I'm
not your typical computer science
founder I studied physics and math and I
was actually planning to go be a
theoretical physicist and be a professor
I got sick of house flow kind of
academia was moving and wanted to build
something that had a more real time
impact on the world there's actually a
lot of shared similarities between oil
entrepreneurship and technology
partnership they really are the two
pillars of the US economy today the
people are very much like a lot of tech
people if they want to go build
something they want to have a big impact
on the world they want to make people's
lives better there's very few places in
the world where it's socially acceptable
to just go start something new and
that's something that's happened a lot
an interview particularly in the last
decade and obviously a lot technology
and I knew when I was starting this
company I wanted to be building a
business that served other entrepreneurs
and there's a lot of oil entrepreneurs
out there that we can help and we can
support with our technology I'm
personally very supportive of going and
developing other sources of energy as
well I think you always want to have as
much possible energy to draw upon and
rely upon the facts are today fossil
fuels are the predominant form of energy
they've had a huge positive impact on
the world and anything we can do to make
them more efficient more cost effective
and more easily accessible to more
people around the world that's a big
positive and so that's what we're
focused on